[موسيقى]
لا تتوقفوا الات الخياطه هنا عن الحياكه
طوال النهار
فالجميع يعلمون ان ما يقومون به هو اولويه
وضروره تخدم القوات الروسيه العامله في
اوكرانيا
مصنع الخياطه هذا هو احد عشرات المصانع
الاخرى التابعه للقطاع الخاص التي لجات
اليها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لسد حاجتها
وزاره الدفاع كانت بحاجه الى كميات اكبر
من العتاد لسد حاجات قواتنا ماذا دفعها
لللجوء الى القطاع الخاص استجبنا لذلك
فورا وحولنا انتاجنا الى خياطه الملابس
العسكريه واكياس النوم
رسلان الطره الى اعاده بلوره عامه لمصنعها
بشكل كامل ليتناسب مع الظروف الجديده
وقامت بتاجيل مشاريعها السابقه اللي يصبح
80% من انتاج المصنع من نصيب وزاره الدفاع
اكثر من ثمانيه الاف كيس للنوم مخصصا
للقوات الروسيه تمت حياكتها هنا في غضون
شهر واحد فقط وعلى الرغم من الاعلان عن
انتهاء التعبئه الجزئيه في روسيا فان
القطاع الخاص لا يزال يلعب دورا مهما في
سد حاجات القوات الروسيه لا سيما في ظل
المشكله التي ازاحت التعبئه الستاره عنها
لم تعرف روسيا تعبئه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ولا يبدو انها كانت تخطط لاستدعاء
اكثر من 300,000 شخصا في ان واحد وعليه
فان التعبئه التي يصفها كثيرون في موسكو
بالطريقه اظهرت النقص الحاده في العداد
العسكريه للقوات الروسيه لدرجه ان كثيرين
من من شميلاتهم التعبئه الطرق لشراء زيهم
العسكري وحافظات الادويه على حسابهم الخاص
لا احد كان يستعدوا
للتعديه اساسيه لدى الوزاره ولكن ان كنا
نتحدث عن اعتاد
وموعده او انتاجها بشكل عادي كل ذلك
تزامنا مع فرض العقوبات وتراكم ازمه
الانتاج والازمتين اللوجسيه والماليه
تاثيرات سلبيه بل على العام في القطاع
الخاص ويستطيع التكلم مع حاجه السوق
السريعا والاهم بالنسبه له الارباح
واستمراريه الانتاج وهو ما قد ينمو عن
امكانيه التعاون بين الجانبين مستقبلا في
السلمه بعد انتهاء العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
سماره روسيا